[music playing]
NARRATOR: In
Montana's Yaak Valley,
Tom and Sean are
laying a trap for one
of the northern Rockies'
most fearsome predators,
the gray wolf.
The wolf population
has come up so high,
and they eat lots of meat.
NARRATOR: At the
sight of a kill that's
less than six hours old--
TOM: Lots of times, you'll
find the dead animal
after it's all eaten
and everything,
but this one hasn't been eaten.
So there's a real, real big
chance they'll come back.
So we're going to
put a couple of traps
on the trails coming in here.
What are you thinking?
These tracks are
going that way.
We put one--
- Base of that tree there?
- Mm-hm.
SEAN: It's a
challenging, challenging
thing, catching a gray wolf.
Sean don't know a lot
about all the different
types of fur-bearers,
but one thing
that Sean does know is wolves.
Let's try and get one
in a footprint here.
I'm using a set, where it's
anchored off to a tree.
NARRATOR: The exploding
wolf population
is a threat to humans,
but also to game animals
that stand to be wiped out of an
area once a wolf pack moves in.
You don't want too
much chain, because then
they can get too
much speed, momentum,
and maybe jump a trap.
So I got about a
seven foot chain.
And in the snow
like this, you can
hide a lot of this stuff in
this nice, soft snow like this,
nice and dry.
I also have a bag
on my trap here,
and that kind of keeps
the mechanisms of the trap
from freezing under the snow.
And the bags are nice
and thin, so they
don't make a bunch of noise
when the wolf first steps on it.
And I'll just set
that right out there
in the main intersection track.
You always want to be
as neat as possible.
I'm always a little
jumpy about standing
anywhere near these sets.
Touching anything, I
wear my rubber gloves.
If you leave any scent
there of human activity,
wolves can smell things like
that, and you won't catch them.
We want it to be
invisible to them,
but you also don't want
too much snow on the trap,
because it won't fire.
Looks good.
You get out of here the same
way I came in, let it all sit
and chill out for a day, and
we should get back in here.
They're close.
That's right.
They are in here.
These wolves, we got to
keep on handle on them.
They're killing the hell
out of our big game,
and we just got to
control them now.
Well, we got a good
chance of catching them.
All right, ready?